we see and hear much less of donald
trump these days
living behind the walls of his private
club mar-a-lago
and his social media exile is far from
over
after a ruling has upheld his ban from
facebook for now
but the tech giant has six months to
make its rules clear
the oversight board actually rejected
the indefinite suspension
uh that facebook had leveled as a
penalty and said that
actually facebook must apply rules that
are clear and consistent and transparent
and the the essentially invented uh
penalty
was was arbitrary in nature and in
nature and
gave too much power and discretion to
facebook
donald trump has been banned from online
platforms since january's riot on
capitol hill
accused of inciting the violence as his
supporters stormed congress
there's no sign twitter is going to
review its span
in less than 24 hours before facebook's
ruling
donald trump launched a website to
publish his posts
where he gave his reaction free speech
has been taken away from the president
of the united states
because the radical left lunatics are
afraid of the truth
he wrote the decision has enraged
supporters
like his palm beach neighbor who founded
the trumpet
fan club every human being in
any country is entitled to both sides
of the news 80 million people believe
in president trump 80 million people
obviously are still out there wanting to
see a different kind of justice
but with that power comes responsibility
and he has responsibility look what he
did for this country
donald trump is now said to be weighing
up options to start his
own social media platform the decisions
to ban him by tech companies
starving him of the attention he loves
but there's a real sense this is going
to change the behind the heavy security
here at mar-a-lago
donald trump is increasingly considering
another run for office in 2024
and he's exploring new ways of reaching
voters
he was heavily reliant on mobilizing on
the likes of twitter and facebook
on the exclusive island donald trump now
calls home
there are mixed views on whether they
want to see him back online
it's fine by me i personally just think
he incites violence so i'm happy to have
him banned for a while longer
i don't always agree with what he says
but i still think everyone should have
that freedom
facebook's decision long term will anger
one side or the other
but it sets a critical precedent for the
treatment of politicians worldwide
sally lockwood sky news in palm beach
florida